he knows that he's in a lot of deep [ __ ]
he's a habitual liar
he's a sociopath he you know gave people
sexually a sexually transmitted disease
on purpose
knowingly and so now he puts up this
apology and then he does his tick tock
apology
bro i didn't know that i could laugh
even harder than from his written note
apology
his tick tock apology was hilarious it
was like one of the worst acting i've
ever seen in my life
he sets up a camera away from him at a
distance he slumps down
he's wearing a hoodie and in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
flipped up this room if you're watching
it on the audio section because the
audio and this was
[ __ ] terrible there was too much mic
bleed but now we're we're back here
again
so uh we have our very special guest
once again we have ed
park cheers my friend so
the last the last time this full and i
did a podcast so
uh we were talking about the shooting
right
and then we took a break to go have
dinner and we were gonna
you know jump on another subject
afterwards
in my perspective we're at the end of
our meal we're pretty
much finishing up and i just hear you
say
it's time slowing down
and i'm like i'm like okay is david
asking me this existential question
because we're past our 30s now we're
getting older
but then like you started having this
twitch
right so like you would like slink down
and then you jump oh [ __ ] slink down and
jump
and you're like time's slowing down man
and i'm like
what's wrong with you okay
so we do a whole podcast right this is
like an
hour and a half in and then we already
eat our meals so this is about two and a
half hours
yeah so i don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening but as ed is talking
what the funny thing is is like we're
having a deep conversation and then i
feel my mind drifting off and i'm like
david you better focus on what this man
is saying they'll be a [ __ ] ass
right so we're having like a deep
conversation about life
his family stuff and i'm like listening
to him but as he's speaking
his mouth is moving but the words are
coming out a lot slower
it's like out of sync yeah and so i'm
like damn dude like david you got to
focus
feelings are going to be hurt hey man
this hot pie is spicy
dude i started remembering these this
this stupid thought that i had in my
head
and i i when time before i said that
line uh is time slowing down
i started thinking about like google
searches i was like i remember a google
search where somebody
ate like some type of crustacean and
they had like weed
and they caused a weird chemical
reaction that caused it to hallucinate
okay
and so i'm like and then i started
thinking to myself as i was thinking
that i'm like
is that even really an article
as i'm eating like crawfish
and in my mind i'm telling myself okay
if you read an article that says that
you having shellfish with this weird
weed that you had
um it causes a weird hallucination why
are you continuing to crack more and
more and more
and continue to eat them and so this is
like this weird conversation i'm having
in my head
and then the moment i asked that
question it was that
in my mind what i saw was me moving my
head this way
and then i couldn't get my head to move
back so
it was just kind of locked here i'm like
david you probably look so stupid
because you're staring at one spot
move your [ __ ] head so ed doesn't
think something's wrong with you and
then i say
it's time slowing down so look at you
and your eyes are like puffy and they're
red
and i'm like okay mike i didn't i
haven't i've never given you weed right
yeah so like i'm a regular smoker but i
never
give my weed to anyone because i've been
in too many situations
where someone's like hey let me try some
of that and they get [ __ ] up
right yeah so i never give my weed to
anyone so i'm like
dude are you high david are you like
you don't smoke though you say you're
like yeah i don't smoke
yeah i didn't smoke anything so i when
you asked me that i remember i had to
sit there and sift through my head
so i started freaking out a little bit
because i'm like did somebody roof me
did somebody put something in my [ __ ]
drink
right or some food we were eating all
night yeah and then the only thing that
i remember
is that i took a tincture right which
was this tincture what is it it's it was
just cbd
right but i think i took too much of it
and then
with that on top of having like three
glasses of [ __ ] tequila oh [ __ ]
i think that [ __ ] mixed together because
those tinctures do have
a little bit of thc i don't react well
the thc at all
so i think that and that together i got
crossfaded
and i remember sitting there right and i
was like yo i was like david you cannot
drive you got to give your keys to ed
and i think i gave you my keys yeah you
it was just
slow motion it was just like i don't
even think you said anything you're just
i think you said you might
better drive like yeah i'm gonna drive
and then like moments later
you need to drive i can't drive i'm like
did i give you my keys
yes man you literally just gave it to me
[Laughter]
dude you know that kind of high like i
i i felt that when i was 15
the first time i ever smoked weed you
know like when i'm with my high school
buddies
we had a little like coke can and you
press the middle of it
put holes in it and put the weed there
and then you
you smoke it out of the lip bro i was a
can
i was lightweight freaking out on the
other side i i was trying not to
uh overreact and have a paranoid go into
like a paranoid frenzy
because at that moment while you were
talking like
colors started popping up oh my god so i
was like this
is this weed what the [ __ ] is this
because as you were talking it was like
have you seen when somebody like a video
of like
um somebody creating like 3d molds of
stuff and it just turns into like spikes
of things
right right right 3d printers time
lapses that's what i was seeing
in all these [ __ ] colors so i
couldn't
i couldn't figure out what was happening
i didn't have never felt like
yeah and then at a certain point i
actually gave up i was like you know
what
i'm actually dead i
i told myself in my head that i died
so i i started picturing myself floating
outside of my body
looking at us having a meal and i'm like
oh i'm dead
this is it this is how i go like so i
was like a few out in my head i'm having
this conversation in my head i'm like
so this is the afterlife and after we're
done with our meal i'm gonna float to
heaven
i gave up i was waiting for god to take
me away
that's not uncommon to so many people i
felt like that where i thought i'm dead
oh this is it i should call my mom
so i'm like david don't don't freak out
yeah don't don't go into this like
paranoid
frenzy because you already died
it's already done it's done you can't do
anything just
just look at your life you just don't
fear it yeah it's happened
and then i remember going into the card
this is one of the funniest parts to me
i remember going into the car
and thinking to myself i have been in
this car for three days
and i was like wait but the restaurant
isn't that far from the house so
it can't be three days your perception
of time got [ __ ]
how can i'm not three days away from my
house so how can this be three days
what no you're laying there so i had to
drive your car
and you're just like this is the longest
ride home right
and then and then you said
why do you like this [ __ ]
man you were talking
in slow motion oh my god dude honestly i
don't remember that
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] funny man i just remember
sitting there
telling myself okay if i've been in this
car for three days
how am i only next to h mart
it's not that far from my house so it
can't be three days it has to be only
maybe three hours i was like wait
it's not even three hours you keep
having these inner like monologues
yes if that's what weed is dude it's
this you're you're talking yourself man
and and it feels like i'm talking to
myself for hours but it's only been a
few seconds oh yeah
it wasn't that far from your house but i
i remember just being like david don't
worry thank god
i think you're gonna freak out i was
like nobody has ever died
from thc well thank god you were there
because i was
internally like i was freaking out yeah
but i think once i made the connection
because
i took the tincture i understood why i
was like this but before
i couldn't piece it together right and
so because i couldn't piece it together
i was dying on the inside i'm like
i'm [ __ ] dead like i'm dead like
god's gonna take me away soon
when i got to the house i was just like
hey don't don't tell mary
like like coincidentally mario came on
the same time
we pulled up and you're like hey hey man
don't tell mary
[Laughter]
all right but you get out and you're
like waddling like a penguin
to your front door and as soon as we get
in
you
[Laughter]
i also kind of remember going in and
like i had my back turned to her
yeah and then i'm looking at you and i
kind of smiled with a little
[ __ ] but you just turned around
chucky i'm high
you went straight to the couch like you
should have
and you just last night i know you just
passed out dog was jumping on you you're
just
dude like i kind of laying on the couch
i remember just going in and out in and
out right because time was
i couldn't grasp time i just didn't know
where i was at
what time it was what was happening but
mario told me i we got back home like
maybe around 5 30 6 o'clock
well i woke up again i woke up around
like 11 or 12.
and uh yeah p.m okay and then when i got
up
i think i got out of bed like around 1am
oh hungry
yo that munchie [ __ ] is real i i woke up
i made like two bags of lamian
i cracked like two eggs i ate that [ __ ]
i grabbed a handful of a fistful of m
ms i shoved it in my mouth i went to bed
i
knocked out fro so basically from five
to about
like one and then from one to two i was
just eating food then from two all the
way till eleven i fell asleep
dude i knocked out for like i don't know
how many hours is that it's a ridiculous
amount of time
that's sleep though so check this out
the day after people were hitting me up
they're like hey you want to play ball
they put the hoops back
up yeah i was like oh cool let's go play
ball i'm still high
and i didn't know i was still high until
we're on the court and we're playing
ball
and then i'm telling i'm telling nick
the story about me being high but i told
him like three times the same story
because i don't know where the [ __ ] i am
and so i didn't know i don't feel high
but that my behaviors are sluggish still
so playing ball this fool passes me the
ball i grab it
and then i just start looking into the
sky
he passes me the ball
[Laughter]
she's [ __ ] cartoon dude
[Laughter]
like i've never been so high this long
in my life dude
so what was in that tincture so what
okay well explain what this tincture is
what is this so it's a cbd company that
sponsors me right and i've used this
tincture before and i and i
love this company it's called cbd
farmhouse it is the best [ __ ] ever right
especially because you know when i get
anxious or i need to fall asleep like
last night i couldn't fall asleep i took
their cbd gummy with a
with a little bit of melatonin right
knocked me that knocked me the [ __ ] out
and i woke up today at seven feeling
great
but this time i didn't have the gummies
i ran out but i did have their tincture
i think what i also did is i took too
much of the dropper
and i just didn't know i was like oh
i'll take a full drop what but the the
drop that i normally take
is just regular cbd this is their delta
eight cbd right and it's it's different
it's a different formula
i didn't know this you know and i just
took a fat dropper and i
what i remember happening was i took a
dropper and i think i
i thought that it was only like a
halfway through so i was like oh just
take another half or another
so i think i took two full droppers
and i drank three glasses of tequila
when's the last time you've
ever smoked we or had thc uh the last
time i had it was when i first started
doing send foods
and it was the it was when i went to
knott's berry farm
and so i couldn't go to sleep so my
buddy roger he used to own or i think he
still does own a bunch of weed farm [ __ ]
yeah so
i've never had an edible before yeah i
actually never smoked weed
yeah because i just never had an
inclination to do it but
you know me i suffered from insomnia
turns out i just it was just because i
was i just never went out in the sun
it was a very quick fix so he decided to
give me a brownie
i take here's the problem with brownies
you don't know where it's concentrated
oh no
right and so when you tell somebody to
take a brownie like an edible
and you tell them just take a corner you
have to tell me what a corner means
right so when i took a corner that means
i ate a quarter of it
what he meant was a nibble at the corner
i chomped a whole fourth of it dude you
like measured it in
equal parts yeah two ports and so i took
a fourth of the [ __ ] brownie dude
and i first of all it wasn't that great
of a [ __ ] sleep like then
it was not great but i woke up the next
day i had to shoot the sen foods episode
with tim at knott's berry farm i was
high
as [ __ ] and so i remember getting out of
bed
and thinking to myself i'm still high
but i was so [ __ ] high and you know
my last townhouse there was three
flights
i had to hold the rails and i was going
down into my uber
i must go to work yeah i was like i have
to i have to make it to work
so i'm going down i get into the uber
and the guy is trying to
chop it up with me just telling me
stories and i'm
blasted and i look at him i go hey hey
hey
i'm [ __ ] high man
the dude goes i got you he just like
turns on some music and he just stays
quiet
and then that's the first time i had
cottonmouth yeah and i
didn't know what cottonmouth was and now
i know it feels like a little cotton
ball is in your mouth and you can't get
rid of it it's just a desert in your
mouth yeah
no matter how much water you drink it
doesn't [ __ ] matter there is
a specific mouthwash for cottonmouth
actually oh really oh it's [ __ ] sold
out too
oh my god that's hilarious yeah you can
get at cvs i forget what it's called but
it's like what
is that [ __ ] i don't know it's just a
side effect of marijuana like just
dehydrating you
i guess yeah because i remember just
keep i just kept drinking water and i'm
like
i can't hydrate myself no it's literally
what hell might be like
yeah and you just it's like you're
drinking water and you're just
you never feel satiated so but at least
you stay hydrated yeah
and so i'm i'm waiting there and then
we're at knott's prayer farm i tell tim
like listen bro i'm [ __ ] high
this is the first time i ever did weed
and i don't like i just need a couple of
minutes
then 30 minutes passed and then
literally it felt like somebody turned
on a light switch and i was okay
okay so if there was no gradual just oh
i'm feeling a little better it just went
click and then my high was gone right
and it felt like there was a demon on me
and it just somebody just did an
exorcism and it left me
there's something about like edibles
where you when you ingest it
like the high shoots up and then the
spike stays constant
right but if you have like a like so
also i think your tincture
reacts the same way because that [ __ ]
lasted a long [ __ ] it lasted almost
two [ __ ] days
yeah and then it like slowly drops down
on you
i just remember the sky was so beautiful
yeah you
and then you had the best ramen of your
life and you're like these eminence are
the best [ __ ] m
ms ever it's weird because when i was
grabbing the m m's too it felt like i
wasn't like this weird
i was definitely the time wasn't slow
anymore yeah but i kind of felt like in
a weird hazy state
i just remember grabbing that m m and
i'm like [ __ ] these m m's are amazing
i shoved this like this grip full of m
m's and threw it in my mouth and i just
started eating it and laying down in bed
chewing m m's
man you need a proper like scheduled
like
safe place where like if you ever want
to do it again and actually like listen
to some music
and then eat some food and like really
enjoy what it's about
well i heard people are telling me that
um the way edibles hit is different from
when you smoke
right it is right edibles are way more
intense
yeah and the only time i've ever done
weed twice was through two edibles
accidentally
like ingesting it yeah and it's crazy
dude
hey if that's the route maybe you might
just keep it with like someone who is a
chef
and like cooks like cannabis ingredients
i will never do weed ever again you just
get into bad situations
i just keep i i mean it's very weird
when you feel like you died
and then you just gave up like i just
was like
gee just take me now my friend gave me
this gravity bomb which
[ __ ] me up and there was the same
point where i was like oh my god i'm
gonna die
and so i just sat at the edge of my
couch like i had
you know i should write a letter to my
sister my brother
i didn't call my mom and then i was
looking at my friend like you should get
ready to call the ambulance
so they can take me to hospital you know
and i was just thinking about this is it
yeah like i'm not scared of death what
is that like what is this feeling where
you just give up and you go i have no
idea it could be in this existential
outer body kind of experience with
getting
too [ __ ] high you know but i don't
think there's a whole lot of study on it
but a lot of people when they
smoke feed you get a
what introspective yeah and and it helps
a lot of it helped me
in that way too i feel like you're very
good with weed like my introspection is
stupid
you know like contemplating whether
three days three hours or three minutes
passed
for which felt like an eternity is
[ __ ] dumb
it felt like like if you have a slinky
and then you kind of start the slinky
and it just gradually goes and at the
end it goes
snaps really fast that's it that's what
it felt like right yeah and that's what
you were doing
you were like you start to slump and
then you'd wake
and then you'd slump and you'd wake like
you weren't having fun
that is [ __ ] hilarious dude i just i
just sounded so funny i'm just telling
myself you better listen to ed's story
right now
don't you [ __ ] don't you stop
listening and then i realize i'm like
wait i'm
high this is why i can't pay attention
like oh my god dude it was one of the
worst experiences of my [ __ ] life
thank god you were there man well
i guess we can finish off we were going
to leave off like we were going to have
this entire
conversation about this event yeah and
you're going to have to fill me in on it
okay because so if you guys were
following me on instagram you guys saw
my live and uh
here's the thing i'm not trying to bully
this kid right
but at the same time i'm trying to bully
this kid
yeah so if you guys know if you saw my
instagram live and there's a good friend
of mine named gina
you guys know this but she has had a lot
of drama recently with a very specific
uh
tick-tocker right right and i've i've
i have a tick tock i don't really do
much stuff with it mainly because the
content that i make it's not allowed on
tick-tock
like you curse or anything else it gets
taken down like i literally put it up
like 10 tick tocks and
only three or four of them are up there
because they get taken down so i've
given up on that platform
um but uh gina
was dating this this this kid right he's
like 24 years old maybe 25
now right so he um
they met each other and i think like her
gina has like a little group of tick
talkers that they all do tick tock
together very very sweet kids very fun
they kind of remind me of myself when i
first started doing youtube so
there are a bunch of they're a
collective of friends that are having
fun and they create content together
really dope um i think i've seen a
couple like yakuza family or some [ __ ]
yeah they do all that they
you know they're having fun on this
platform it's actually pretty cool they
so gina ends up dating one of these guys
and you know they were they were they
were going on for a while and they broke
up
so at that event that we had so there's
this app called taco
uh david choi's new app and basically
it's it's a form of social media that's
kind of made for creators where you can
make money off of it
so a lot of these social media platforms
that are created these platforms aren't
created
in mind of the creator first but taco is
the opposite
it's creator made so creator based first
right right so this is why you see a lot
of tick talkers who
have 2 million followers and they make
400 bucks a month damn
you know damn so i i had a neighbor
in the last place that i lived her kid
actually is a huge tick tocker
handsome boy half japanese half black
cute as [ __ ] and this dude does like
tick tock dances but he has like two
million followers yeah
and then uh i was like oh how many
followers does he have and she was like
oh he has two
i was like wow you must be really proud
she goes i would be proud if he wasn't
broke
and i'm like what do you mean how is he
broke she goes yeah i mean i think he'll
start selling merch and you know
merchandise and stuff like that but from
the platform makes him like 400 bucks a
month 500 bucks a month
i'm like holy [ __ ] you have that huge of
a following and you make
pennies and so exactly so
taco is the exact opposite of that so
the moment you become
um a creator on that app and ads run
you're getting a piece of it yeah that's
[ __ ] dope
yeah it's honestly how it should be
right so for example when tick tock
first opened up
tick tock was a billion dollar company
within like the first first or second
fiscal year
creator saw zero dollars so that means
all this content was created
by creators that company became a
billion dollar company
while creators saw zero and they
basically built that platform yeah
and so now they're doing monetization on
it you can run some ads but because it
wasn't
based as an app for creators it's hard
to integrate money into it later on
yeah you see that with youtube you see
that with everything else
and so we were at this taco event and it
was a drive-through night right so they
invited a bunch of
influencers you know we're friends of
david he invited us there to just have
some food hang out
yeah i went with uh clara and um
yeah we saw each other right but i
didn't know what happened after this
yeah so i'm over here i'm talking to the
people at panda express right shout out
to them i [ __ ] love you panda express
we love panda
and so you know i'm chopping it up with
them two sweet sweet ladies
we're having a good time and then i see
gina off in the distance
i've known gina now for 10 years i know
when she looks pissed
so she's walking up to me and i see this
angry little [ __ ] vietnamese girl
just coming up to me
and she hugs me super tight and she's
gripping me really close it's because
she's trying to talk to me she goes
my ex-boyfriend is here he knew i was
gonna be here
he parked in front of my car and he has
another girl inside and we just broke up
two weeks ago
so he's doing this weird little like
power play thing
like you know you know like like young
douchebags do and i'm like
that's [ __ ] weird and i'm kind of
joking around saying oh what are we
gonna do we gonna jump them or something
that's a joke whatever right
the night continues to go on and uh all
gina and her tick tock buddies they're
all a part of the same group so they
notice this dude and like yo what kind
of [ __ ] move is this because they all
know him too was like why would he do
that
so later on that day gina texted me back
she goes oh it turns out
hey i actually have chlamydia so
this dude had chlamydia and he gave it
to her
right so this is already pretty bad
right and i'm seeing this on her
takedown she's letting this whole story
be known on tiktok
yeah so mind you he gives her chlamydia
whatever he has chlamydia he has to get
checked to all whatever right
i i saw that it was like nine part video
and she just
[ __ ] burned the walls down to flame
this kid right
so this dude the google docs the
receipts yeah
is apparently he's like a player which
was so weird because as i'm reading this
stuff here i'm like
it's also a representation of some of
these girls it's like yo do you fell for
this [ __ ] because i showed that
google drive to some of my other
homegirls right and they're like this
guy has zero game
and they're like it's almost like
comical right
like i'm not like that's i mean whatever
they might might have gotten you from
i don't know you guys got bedazzled by
his two million tick tock followers and
his 300
in his bank account but this guy
knowingly has chlamydia right and so you
know because gina assumed that he had
chlamydia because he cheated on her with
somebody else so it may have just been
him and another girl
but there are multiple women who caught
chlamydia from him and the
first girl that he gave chlamydia to
told him that yo
we have chlamydia and he still chose to
hook up with gina after unprotected and
he hooked up with multiple girls knowing
that he had chlamydia
holy [ __ ] which in california is like
you can go to jail for that [ __ ]
you could you could press charges this
little kid's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right what of what a dog what
yo i thought like he's technically is
that gen z
he's gen z yeah he's gender i thought
they were the most like
educated yeah they are not
and then after all you know gina flames
him on the whole the whole on her
tick tock kind of goes through this
whole story shows the google drive and
docs about him trying to manipulate all
these [ __ ] women he gives all these
women chlamydia
he puts out an apology talking about how
he's righted his wrongs
only four hours after she posted her
thing
so you i cracked the [ __ ] up i was like
bro you don't even know how to apologize
he goes i finally figured out what i've
done wrong in four
hours like bro how did you
do it in four [ __ ] hours this is
about me
and me and me my grandfather and me
[Laughter]
when i read an apology it was i've never
read something so
self-absorbed in my life and it sounded
like a man-splained apology
exactly it was so [ __ ] funny
it's like i know what a virtuous man is
and this
is what good is and this is and i didn't
reach that standard or whatever it's
like
dude you're like this kid is a he's a he
legit
needs like psychological help because
he's a sociopath
yeah i mean for him he actually did this
whole video where he was doing like a
an interview which so funny like you
have you're a tick talker and you think
that you're important enough to [ __ ]
do interviews about life
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
kid but he was kind of going on this
diatribe about how men are weak
weak men only use online dating tools
as he is has an online dating profile
and he's only talking to women through
tick tock and instagram
it's like that's the same thing you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i was like here's here's here's how
hilarious that is
this is the pure example of a sociopath
yeah like they
literally don't know what the [ __ ]
they're saying
they and they're talking about
themselves he has this
mirror that he's talking to and he
doesn't even recognize it
right he sees right through it and it's
so [ __ ] hilarious i mean he's a young
kid right but
the but the reason why i don't think
this kid can change is because he
actually needs
like clinical help and if he doesn't get
the clinical help he's
it's impossible for him to change he's a
projectionist exactly right like he sees
this [ __ ] in him
but he's gonna flip it because he has a
righteousness to what he does
but everyone else is a piece of [ __ ] and
that's like
some of the most childish adolescent
ways of looking
you want to hear how much this full is a
[ __ ] predator so this dude
we found out that this kid
at the taco night right yeah because
he's so ballin he drives like this 2004
camry
this white tooth out the girl that he
tells uh to come
in that car or it was like somebody else
that he was trying to get to come with
he told her like hey this this drive-in
movie night
is a formal event and it you have to
match
what the color of my car is my 2004
white camry
and says you have to wear a dress too
what this is what he tells his date
this [ __ ] rapist basically what he's
trying to do is to get her to wear a
dress so he can go up her skirt
that's the only reason why you would do
something like that straight up
i'm this this is not facts but it's you
have to understand how weird somebody is
to tell a girl like hey you have to
match the color of my car when we go to
this formal event
a drive-in movie and wear a dress
what's wrong with this guy this guy is a
[ __ ] sociopath
he's [ __ ] nuts yeah this guy needs to
get
this podcast is brought to you by better
help
my friends if you are concerned about
your mental health or you just need
somebody to talk to to sort things out
in your head
then you have to try better help see i
have been using better help for
man it's been it's been like a couple of
years now during the time when i was
trying to find
um therapy or counseling going in person
was kind of hard it kind of felt a
little weird and better help kind of
gave me an option where i could do it
from the comfort of my home and allowed
me to be more comfortable which allowed
me to open up
now i know a lot of people out there
don't talk too much about mental health
and if they do
it doesn't seem like they apply it in
their lives well try out better help
it's been something that i use on a
consistent basis and the great thing
about that is is like if you don't like
your first counselor you could
switch it out with somebody else and it
just makes the user experience
so easy for you the cool thing about
betterhelp 2 is actually a lot more
affordable than traditional
off-site counseling and on top of that
they do have financial aid stuff
available for people out there who might
be worried about the cost
so there really isn't a reason for you
not to try this out but this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and
geniusbrainlisteners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
genius once again that's betterhelp.com
genius so please remember give it a try
you won't regret it and there's nothing
to lose
if you want somebody to talk to you have
things to sort out or you just need
something for that mental clarity try
better help once again that's
betterhelp.com
genius i don't know sounds like someone
without
who doesn't actually have any real
mentorship or hyung
possibly i mean what kind of hyung would
see this little check-in just be like
you can exist dude a lot of swords he
goes to church too
oh we're going there and he goes typical
he's the he's the church young oh the
predator church
the [ __ ] nopa oppa yeah
i'm gonna pray for your heart and your
[ __ ] please
he's one of those [ __ ] because
a lot of like church members from his
group were messaging on like open
comments like oh i know this guy from
church he's a [ __ ] creep oh my god
do you know what i'm saying yeah and so
this young man is a huge
[ __ ] trash bag here's the [ __ ]
topper right this is the craziest [ __ ]
gina was do i went on live with gina and
he was talking about his military
service right because
and let me tell you something i have
never heard of such a ridiculous lie in
my life
like he's lying about his military
service so he walks around telling
people that he was
he goes you know what this is the
funniest [ __ ] dude
when people are terrible liars like when
they're like habitual liars in their
sociopaths
they don't see a cap to their lie
and so it becomes so ridiculous it's
highly apparent it's [ __ ] stupid
yeah right but people get kind of get
lost in the sauce so they allow them to
go ahead and tell this story
so gina tells his [ __ ] uh
gina tells this [ __ ] funny story
where he was telling this girl
that you know he goes oh i'm in the navy
and then she starts opening up to him
about
um in her past she had like people who
like sexually assaulted her and then so
he takes that information
and he fabricates a lie to go on top of
what she's saying and he goes
you know what i did in the navy i was
positioned to hunt down rape
rapists and sins what i'm like
bro there is no position in the navy
where you're this [ __ ] serial rapist
hunter [ __ ]
rogue maverick and seal like [ __ ]
[ __ ] special special special forces
like what he's a special ops navy
rapist hunter so he just starts
fabricating these [ __ ] lots 25 years
old
all right bro do you know what i'm like
it's [ __ ] hilarious
and listen i have friends in the [ __ ]
navy
right they said they don't do much
this is not me [ __ ] on that military
i'm talking about my
friends in the navy say it's it's pretty
cool yeah
you know your brother was in the navy
yeah and i mean like yeah i mean
this my yeah my brother tells me to he
just hates the
the military types who glorify
themselves
yeah yeah he sees that a lot where they
lift themselves up
like and like call themselves special
and like i see my brother with the way
he explains it
like he has ptsd but he doesn't
he's just like the stern korean style
where he's just
like well here's the thing too i don't
know anybody in the military that has
seen or done [ __ ]
that likes talking about it that openly
to everybody they [ __ ] know
on their tick tock on their tick tock
yeah so
i have a friend too um
it's um you know victor kim he was he
was so victor kim
his brother david was in the marines
right and he was special ops in the
marines he did overseas bodyguard stuff
and everything else
and i remember asking him about what
he's seen out there this is during the
time the the iraq war was happening
right
um and um he was just like you don't
ask people in the military that because
it's kind of like
traumatic he was very kind to me when he
feels like but you know it's kind of
insensitive i'm like oh [ __ ] i never did
it again
because i didn't think that i'm like oh
this might be some cool stories that he
wants to share
but the things that he's done and he's
seen it's not something that he's really
comfortable talking about
and there's so there's some people who
are yeah but they're not going to say it
on a public platform they're not going
to really do that
yeah and so but this kid's over here
telling people i'm a i'm a rapist hunter
on a boat
on a submarine i go rogue no
same i had a we had a hung at our church
um
and one of my friends was doing like he
counts the offering
he's like yo this guy is tithing it's
like
almost like a stack right yeah
and he is special forces or whatever and
so we're at applebee's we're like um
like what's up yeah what's going on out
there and he's just like
you just need to know that there's bad
guys
and there's good guys and he wouldn't
say anything else
that's it and he would not tell us he's
probably tithing because of like
he has to do things that he doesn't want
to do and he's like he's like
feels i i have to do this yeah dude and
so it's that it's ridiculous to see this
kind of
like i don't know how long he's served
but it's just like who who does that
dude well that's what i'm saying here's
the funny thing too so uh one of those
kids
his name is uh saint right yeah and so
uh they told me that
they confronted him after because saint
is actually in them he's in the marines
yeah
and so he started asking him questions
like qualifying questions that anybody
who has applied to be in the military
should know these questions it's that
basic he goes i don't remember
i don't know you know all that combat
just made me forget it
had to look all those rapists in the eye
who knew about formalities
that was that was the dementors
they were everywhere upside down
i couldn't get my spell off right it
wasn't working
this guy is just being [ __ ] stupid
like this guy is hilarious like i can't
help but
laugh at this person dude because of how
ridiculous he is
let me tell you this story gets worse so
okay
down the rabbit hole he sees his
reputation going down the rabbit hole
right
it's it's it's [ __ ] terrible you
[ __ ] knowingly gay people chlamydia
you lied about your military you're
lying about your military service whatev
whether how long you've been in the
military or not you might have been
whatever cool well at this point you got
to show pictures of you being in the
navy
you know or how long you've been in it
because if you went to the navy and he's
like i served six months and people were
like six months
six months man that's special
like you worked out man you had basic
training got a rocking body and came out
dude
this fool went to the navy for six
months they're like you've done all you
can
so you know everybody in the comments
are like questioning his military
there's people who have been in the
military
yeah so he knows that he's in a lot of
deep [ __ ]
he's a habitual liar he's a sociopath
he you know gave people sexually a
sexually transmitted disease on purpose
knowingly and so now he puts up this
apology and then he does his tick tock
apology
bro i didn't know that i could laugh
even harder than from his written note
apology
his tick-tock apology was hilarious it
was like one of the worst acting i've
ever seen in my life
he sets up a camera away from him at a
distance he slumps down
he's wearing a hoodie and he kind of
squints like he's about to fart he goes
i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up bro
i showed my buddy nick and pat that
video they burst out laughing
immediately they're like is this a
parody or is this the actual
it looked like a parody are you on save
by the bell
are you a [ __ ] full house like i'm
sorry
mister i i made a mistake like what
and it goes into the second clip this is
how you know
he should have written this down if you
if you are an aspiring actor young man
you should have written down this
apology and stuck to it
because this was terrible he i [ __ ] you
not if you look at that video hopefully
it's still up he goes
i just want to apologize to all the
africans and indians
i'm like excuse me what do you mean he
goes i understand what you guys have
been going through now
so i want to apologize to all the
african indians
and i can't make this [ __ ] up you could
go watch the video yourself
but it's like but if you're but if you
are white and i give you chlamydia you
deserve it
i'm kidding
this kid is the worst he's [ __ ]
terrible
this gets even worse so he has like his
little group of like twitch followers
right okay these
people on his twitch following who are
supposed to be as hardcore fans
not all of them are as hardcore fans
they're just there so they could hear
more [ __ ] that he's gonna say so he has
like this small little group
he tells these twitch followers like hey
i'm just going to apologize because this
stuff is going to blow over anyways
like i'm pretty sure gina is the one
that gave me chlamydia so i'm just going
to wait for this to die out and i'm
going to come back
so he's not even apologetic just [ __ ]
fool thought that oh this is a
club my closest friends not knowing that
it was a
public twitch thing and they came back
and they started telling everybody else
like hey
guess what he's lying he he'd never
apologize he's just doing this so he
could die over so he can go back to his
career
this is how terrible this he is a
sociopath this kid is nuts
oh man i think uh perhaps
in our our han
you know way of getting back is just to
make sure he doesn't try to come back
how can you be
poor and that cocky like this kid is
broke it's like you're a
broke [ __ ] kid you might make more
money as a bartender off tips
oh a hundred percent but this is what
i'm saying it's like your your social
currency is a representation of how
[ __ ] cool you are
like even in this apology video it looks
like a dorm room yeah like you're 25
weren't you in the military you didn't
make any money off of that yeah what the
[ __ ] are you talking about dude
it's like how could you be that cocky
like his car was so busted i'm like bro
i i legit saw his car and i thought that
he was gonna break the bottom off and
start going off on a yabba-dabba-doo
good old time dude
hey i used to drive that yeah 15 years
15 years
yeah i had that car and guess what i was
poor as [ __ ]
and i didn't [ __ ] act like i had a
[ __ ] ton of money i was dope i was like
no i'm kind of broke and i understand
this yeah
i'm not making fun of people who had
camrys i had that car
i had that [ __ ] car so i know what's
up yeah
you know what i mean like it's it's the
most it's ridiculous like
for him to stand like as a 25 year old
kid
you are nothing you literally were just
born yesterday
right you're not that much younger than
i am but at the same time
when i was that age i didn't act like i
knew everything
you know what i mean i mean you could
argue that the fame coming at him
litigated so much of the delusion in his
head young ladies out there if you ever
[ __ ] somebody because they were a tick
tock star
you are trash
if that's all it takes to get in your
pants have some [ __ ] self-respect
like i understand a little bit if he's a
tick-tock dude he makes good money
he could take you on trips or whatever
he's smart
intelligent has something going on right
but the man makes trashy [ __ ]
tick-tock comedy videos and you're like
my pussy's win what's the lesson here
for
like let's say influencers and people
dealing with their integrity here this
[ __ ] just
i mean i mean you gotta say maybe a lot
of people who listen in
our car might see themselves in this guy
like oh [ __ ] i lie a lot
to get by yeah right a lot of people
might not don't you know here's the
thing these people don't
know that they keep getting away with
lying
and it just like validates
their thought process their delusions
their feelings and like
their ego and they get caught up in this
their own lie the same way like have you
seen the ric flair documentary the 30
30. i haven't seen it uh spoiler alert
basically it's a deep dive into his
psyche and who he is
and now as an old man he's almost 70
right
he's not ric flair from when he was 20
years old trying to get into direction
like wrestling yeah right this rick
flair like
is his character right his k fave for
wrestling and they said over time that's
who just he
became so when they keep trying to make
him like retire or something
he cannot not be ric flair
that's hilarious and you're seeing it
with these young influencers
that those numbers like a hundred
thousand there's a lot of [ __ ]
followers yeah there's a lot of people
kid yeah you know i mean that's a big
[ __ ] audience
and it gets to these people like i see
it in a lot of young kids
like they lose who they are by their
social presence
and their identity is stuck with their
selfies yeah and their social presence
and it wow and it's you know that's such
a good point because
i don't wha
how do you how do you not do this then
you know
for for kids like how do you
use this app right whether it's tick
tock instagram or twitter
how do you use it without it letting it
take over your life
right because we see this a lot right
there was
right now the hottest thing to do is be
a social justice warrior
right if you're not a social justice
word you're just not cool like we're
looking and i say this
you know i say this repetitiously
because i truly do believe it there are
too many people who are looking for
a pat on the back and i even see this
with personal colleagues of mine where i
have to unfollow their [ __ ]
because i know like because of all the
asian hate stuff like their influence
and they're doing asian hate things
right now they were never saying this
before
and i know these people they're not
doing this because
they care they're doing it because they
know that all i have to say is because
i'm an asian influencer
and i know it's going to get me views
and it's just like
this is what it is now like you and also
too like people are also thinking like
you don't know any of these people at
all on on the social platforms
as much as i mean i guess like for me
because you guys listen to this podcast
and i'm pretty open and honest
when you meet me in person i'm pretty
much the same guy that you see on this
camera right like maybe not the vlogs
vlogs are aggrandized it's performative
right this is not performative at all
this is just us having a conversation so
you do get a general feel of who i am
right you have nothing to hide you are
undead honestly yeah you know so yeah
you know whether i'm right or wrong or
whatever like it's just these are just
thoughts right and then we could always
have a conversation to
discuss it further so with when i have
like some of these kids who
who live in this youtube social media
world
i don't even know if they have they've
even developed the time to be a real
human being
because they're so busy developing their
fake persona they don't they aren't
developing themselves first
exactly you know right it's easy to to
write things and say all this other [ __ ]
right there was that
um i think they took that post down or i
think their channel got taken down it
was that person that was
uh trying to slander me over they called
you a hypocrite they
did a [ __ ] side by side we don't have
to say what they are but we know
yeah but i think that thing got taken
down good because everybody was
calling them out they're like no no this
is a bit of a stretch right
because they didn't know that this young
lady was calling uh
black american savages low-class human
beings
right yeah they didn't know that but
they went out of their way
because they wanted to give brownie
points and obviously they're clearly
friends or something and they follow
each other
because i could tell by their
interactions i saw it once i'm like this
is dumb i'm not gonna even respond to
this
because it's so stupid and everybody's
doing it for me you did
the bigger man thing and you even had to
tell your followers
hey don't attack her don't attack her
that you shouldn't have to do that
guess what this [ __ ] did send her
[ __ ] insult fans at me
right yeah you have exponentially larger
scale of followers on social media and
you told them don't attack her
yeah right because she has much smaller
yeah but she has an
even bigger exponential scale of
followers than i do
and she said like just sucked her
[ __ ] incel dogs at me
we're intel dogs too they're also
inherently racist yes they
hate black americans yes they kept
trying to convince me to start blaming
black people for these asian attacks
yeah it's like
you're never gonna win racist and she's
already incredibly racist herself yes
like it's not even like racist in the
sense of like oh she has like slightly
microaggressions
i'm telling you she legit said that
black americans are savages and the
reason why they are that they they are
that way is because they're dumb and
they can't get themselves out of the
situation
she deleted those comments when she
responded back i i wish i would have
screen capped it
i'm i [ __ ] you not i'm not making this
up we've seen it i've seen it
they're just gone now she's deleted
[Laughter]
and you know when somebody goes out of
the way and they say oh the reason why
you are is because you're dumb and
you're savage
i think that's racist yeah i think
that's pretty [ __ ] apparent
and somehow this other asian american
who runs this channel is saying that i'm
a hypocrite
because i'm standing up for asian
americans it's like no i am standing up
for asian americans but i don't
have to step on the necks of somebody
else
to show that we're going through some
other [ __ ] too you know what's upsetting
to me about that as an editor
is that if you're an editor you need to
have foresight
of what you're creating and what this is
going to do when you put it out there
yeah this [ __ ] had a time to
watch two of these videos
your all of them and he screen capped it
so that you can record it and put it
into an editing system
so he can play and he heard what you
[ __ ] said
yet still manipulated it and deleted it
out and took it out
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you mishandle
the [ __ ] privilege of what it means
to be a filmmaker [ __ ]
i hate you for that for your racist
agenda you [ __ ] yeah they
specifically took
out the reason why she was being
attacked yeah you know you know what i
mean
and it's so funny too like like people
were telling me that because people are
dming me and this is personal friends
like she's trying to spin this narrative
that i'm telling other people to attack
her it's like
young lady i could give a [ __ ] queef
about
like [ __ ] if if you died tomorrow
i would not know like
legit if you [ __ ] died tomorrow i
would not know
i wouldn't shed a tear if you apologize
to me i still wouldn't care
cause i don't care about you she came
into
my comment sections on my [ __ ] to
question my masculinity and me being not
being a man or whatever
while saying blm is a terrorist
organization how and saying how dare you
call me
a racist blm is a terrorist organization
that slander like you just proved
yourself wrong in the same sentence
that's what i'm saying like people have
to leave her alone
because she's dumb she's so stupid like
she's like
i should have the balls to tag her in a
post and your
fat friend david you know you know you
wouldn't say this if you're
wasn't friends with him and i'm like why
don't you tag david yeah why don't you
just
[ __ ] about it because she can and i got
pissed that she called you
fat and your looks and [ __ ] right
because hey i was fat too
yeah and you know what [ __ ] i lost a
hundred [ __ ] pounds and my ass is
still [ __ ] fatter than this
well the funny thing is too it's like
[ __ ] you ain't even cute like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about nothing about
you that's interesting behind yourself
you look like you're 20 and you're 45 at
the same time
like what the [ __ ] you look like an ajay
man that looks kimchi for a living
i wasn't going to say the same thing
like she looked like i bought a nice
kimchi for a living and she saw over
here like trying to be like i'm a hot
model
[ __ ] relax right and listen i'm not
trying to berate you on your looks i'm
only doing that because you you're
coming at other people based on their
looks so here's the thing like i
i just find it hilarious right that
people you you can't
ration you can't rationalize
with somebody who is stupid right right
i don't mean this to insult her
i'm saying it as a fact she is actually
dumb
so you have to pity them you pity thing
there's there's nothing else you could
have seen
yeah it's really really [ __ ] sad and
the thing is a dumb person will look at
somebody with who has reason and look at
them like they're stupid
so it's cyclical there's nothing that
you can do so that's what i'm saying
you guys got to just leave her alone
well i think there's a like a
slight nuance there though yeah i don't
think there's
there's nothing wrong with not knowing
something right and so someone called
you stupid of course then in essence
therefore i say
there's not anything inherently wrong
with being stupid it just means you
don't know
because you have the capacity to know
right and learn later
there's something wrong when you're
[ __ ] told the objective truth
and you deny it yeah you know it makes
you insane yeah
it's to be stupid on purpose that's
impressive listen i can go i can go into
my dms yeah and
go ahead and screencap everybody who's
had a personal interaction with her
to talk about how [ __ ] trashy she is
yeah like as a human
being like i have stories and dms for
days about people who have met her
about the things she's done just to get
photos from somebody there are so many
disgusting stories i know about her
but let's not even get into that hearing
those stories made me realize
she is not a person who is sane so
if she's willing to do certain things
like that for photos i think that i
should leave her alone and there's no
point to have this conversation right
and the people who are backing her up
are [ __ ] do we be
ugly greasy looking [ __ ] asian dudes
that think they want to [ __ ] this 40
year old kimchi making lady dude
so i'm like calling me a [ __ ] and like
questioning of course
they would never do anything to you in
person i'm not an influencer so i'm like
dealing with this hate mail and that
there i'll tell you this i've walked
around
loud as [ __ ] i'm very i am v i'm
somebody that's very noticeable yeah
not a single person has ever come up to
me said hey you're a little [ __ ] let's
throw down
[Laughter]
because you wouldn't do it okay yeah
nobody would do it
right the only reason why somebody would
do that to me is if i personally attack
them
right yeah but there's absolutely no way
that somebody goes out of the way types
something up and says let's meet up and
let's [ __ ] throw it
throw down because you're not going to
do that i'm not going to show with fists
either full i'm gonna come out with a
[ __ ] bat and break your [ __ ]
kneecaps
so it's like you and i grew up very
differently that that's the thing we
also grew up in a very
weird age right like we didn't have this
digital net to go ahead
it was like if you said some [ __ ] on aim
like we're gonna meet behind the market
yeah let's meet at the park let's
[ __ ] throw down and let's see what
happens whether you're a geek
nerd or whatever there's a certain
amount of honor and pride that people
have
but nowadays that thing doesn't exist
right flies now
just [ __ ] fly yeah they just say
whatever the [ __ ] that they want and you
know these people to probably live in
los angeles
it's like you'll see me you could do
something if you want
you know i i won't do anything back to
you i'd probably call the cops
you know there was a lot of processing i
had to do just to be like okay this is
false he's saying false things he's
false things and
he did none of these [ __ ] know
me and then i looked through their
profile like
they have massive pokemon card
collections exactly it's like massive
like xbox collections of games and they
were probably bullied too
you know so like i understand like i
kind of feel for them a little bit and
they're misdirecting a lot of their
anger
and they're championing they're
championing their this this [ __ ] 40
year old lady
to be their [ __ ] heroine you know i
think a few of them though
um actually looked through my profile
and saw that i used to
look like them and i was like i have
hope yeah
just be like hey i think they figured
hey i'm actually kind of cool
well they get caught up in their
emotions and once again oh it's because
they're
worshipping her yeah they poor someone's
attacking our queen
i have to save her i have to protect her
dude yeah you know what i mean so
they're they're trying to make sure that
she's okay and that she's fine and that
they can measure this is what i said to
this guy i backed you up
and then they go off and she goes thank
you baby heart heart
and then they look at the heart and they
jack off to it and they go you know what
one day she's
gonna suck up my d yeah you know it
happened bro it's gonna happen
so i mean it's it's sad it's it's really
sad you know
but like i said i i had to do this
message because if people are attacking
her like there's no point
what are you gonna do to her you're not
gonna do [ __ ] to her let her be she's
gonna be like that for the rest of the
rest of her life
because she is actually dumb yes like
when somebody
like yeah willfully she's dumb you know
somebody like that other kid that could
read
you know the chlamydia boy like
chlamydia boy
he might have an ability to change
because he's 25 years old yeah you know
she's in her 40s so
she doesn't have a lot to change he's 25
years old
and so he has time but because he's a
sociopath
and he doesn't see anything that he's
doing wrong even up until this point
that he goes out of his way to tell
people hey
i'm actually not sorry at all i'm in the
right just wait for me to come back
he doesn't have an ability to change so
he needs to burn he does not deserve a
platform he doesn't deserve to make any
money off of everybody else
and this is information that people
should know yeah for sure i mean like
i've had a lot of thinking to do like
even my friends were like are you all
right
like because of the hate i was getting
and
like one friend nobody asks me why don't
anybody care about mine
or tyson so what about me
i'm over here i haven't fought in 13
years and you guys don't
care about me we all believe dave david
you can handle your own
look you know you're just like
[Laughter]
don't worry about that he's okay yeah no
we're good
but i just had to be like you know in
these situations it's like
she's so close yet so far right it's
like what do we have in common
we both don't like this asian hate we
both don't like our elderly being
attacked we're both semi-conservative
actually yeah
but what are you missing what are you
missing
you know that's what you gotta think
about it's it's it's it's been a very
very [ __ ] weird time man like having
to see and i i
i haven't been here here's the hard part
for me too when i do these posts right
i do these posts because it's something
that i feel there's some things that i
care about
i can put a funny spin on it i don't
know what it is right but i
i can talk i can speak very well right
um
problem now is that everybody expects me
to scream for them
you know and they don't understand like
the emotional toll that it has
for me to constantly read and see
and be emotionally invested to all these
things that are happening
i'm not saying that i'm emotionally
detached and i don't see them but you
guys want me
to be this angry fireball 24 7. look at
what you're used to then
every sunday you wake up early morning
to sing happy songs of freedom
right when you go to church and then you
hear inspiring messages
you know and you're ready for your week
something changed in your life where
everyone's sending you [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] here get angry at this get angry at
this get angry at this and then all of a
sudden you got to start
preparing for a angry sunday and here's
the thing too and this is what i want
people who are
who are leaders out there who want to
hold these press conferences and
whatever right and they're asking me to
be a part of it yeah
listen i'm glad to do it however
no i am not the person that you should
be contenting about this
there are elected officials who are
asian american there are people who
could actually make a real difference
that you should be contacting i know
it's easy to come and talk to me because
you feel like i'm the voice right
cool you know why they're used to so
many people being like yes i will
yeah i will take the calls for my people
yeah
but for me to be honest with you there
are so many things that i don't know
i should not be on a platform yet to go
ahead and speak
like that i can only talk about my
personal thoughts and how i feel about
it
but i'm a comic guys yeah
you know you have to expect people not
to take everything seriously
yeah like i'm a comic like if i i
it's hard sometimes because i think
people now only expect me to be this
this
political figure it's like me i make
dick and tit jokes there's so many
people out there that can do so much
better
and also too there are people who don't
have my platform
who don't have a huge following that can
speak better than i can too and have all
the right information
exactly you gotta find those people you
know let me do what i do occasionally
here and there and i'm gonna i'm going
to speak i'm gonna be at rallies i'll do
all that stuff but
when you want somebody to go ahead and
describe all the
you know the political issues these
cultural issues there are so many other
people that are better at this than me
and you need to find those people who
could speak you just need to make sure
that you give them the right platform
yeah i think people got
lost in the idea of influencers yeah
because you'll see like
[ __ ] dietitians getting [ __ ] like why
aren't you talking about asian hate
like like they talk about health and
fitness
yeah you know like it's like why aren't
you using your platf
why aren't you using your that it's just
like
when i was on ig live there was a kid
who asked and it was a really good
question and i and i think
from what i felt i think he thought i
was going to say something different
and so on the ig live he was asking me
uh
how do i feel about influencers who
choose not to say anything during these
times
and i think i was going to say look they
have a responsibility to speak up
and what i said was i don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i don't give a [ __ ] right because
number one i'm not their parent i don't
control their platform
also too some people just aren't good at
speaking right
some people deal with anxiety some
people can't deal with that that
pressure to have people
look at and kind of scrutinize
everything that they're saying about a
serious topic
so who am i to look at them and say hey
why didn't you do this
i didn't are they comfortable doing this
stuff are they used to having that much
people come at them when they talk about
very serious subjects
they're not this is idea that young kids
have because of this
old ass saying that if you have any type
of common sense you will know that this
does not ring
ring true at all it's saying something
is better than saying nothing
that is not true when you are [ __ ]
hooked up
shut the [ __ ] up right because if you do
believe that right then you must love
uh the the nikki park you must love her
because she said something
and then would it better for her to say
nothing than anything at all it's just
uncalled for
exactly you crossed the line you just
have to be smarter about your stuff it's
just been such a
weird i like i'm trying i get i
understand though because i see a lot of
myself in them
you know when i was like 26 27 that was
only like what five years ago yeah but i
see a lot of myself doing that
no but they're growing up in a world
right now where that is actually uh
rewarded
it's rewarded now you know god you're so
good you're so woke
yo it's the new church right if no one's
going to youth group
like i think wokeness is a new theology
it's ever-changing it's evolving and
then there's pronouns
and there's adjectives and there's or
whatever so much language to it
dude it's the new theology yeah it's
it's i mean we're we're now a part of a
time and we're at an age now where we're
gonna have to learn how to adjust to
what the youth brings on right
like somebody got upset at me and this
was like a few months back
and i had to check this person because i
got upset at them back
because i didn't understand what they
were asking and instead of taking a
position to say
oh he doesn't understand let me explain
this person got mad at me and i was like
hold on a second don't get [ __ ] mad
at me
i'm asking so for example so they they
asked me they're like
oh they said what are your pronouns and
i didn't know what that was
right and i was like what do you mean
right and they're like like he her she
him i was like
what i've never heard of this before i
didn't know yeah
okay yeah i was like it's fair in my
mind i was like
are you trying to diss me right now yeah
i was like are you calling me a [ __ ]
i didn't know what was going on and
they're like like oh it's like well i
was like you're prone you know what that
means it kind of game i was like hold on
a second
and i looked and i was like yo i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah i was like right now i could tell
that you're upset you know
but you have a position right now to
tell me what the [ __ ] you're saying i
was like i don't know why you're asking
me he
was like oh because they explained it
after i was like that's all you had to
do
so why the [ __ ] are you going here like
getting mad at me when i'm asking you a
question
i'll call you whatever the [ __ ] you want
i just don't know what the [ __ ] you were
saying
it's the same um analogy that i'd given
before where it's like
um yo like you like my shirt
like don't you think my shirt is dope
but you're telling a blind guy
and then he's like sorry i literally
don't see it and then that guy goes
what why not what the [ __ ] why can't you
and it's just like
to a blind guy you have to use a
different language a different type
you have to teach them you have to
describe it your shirt to them right
here
break it down for them and here's the
thing the idea of these pronouns being
like an unlimited amount of pronouns or
whatever whether i believe it or not or
subscribe to it or not
it's a relatively new idea which means
there was a point where you didn't know
either
like so how [ __ ] dare you yeah like
that
yes seriously you know what i mean like
you probably just found out three weeks
ago you [ __ ]
yeah you know that's
that's some [ __ ] righteous fury too
right back at you [ __ ] like
don't get mad at me
yeah like you were you were just me a
month ago you [ __ ] [ __ ] like why
couldn't you have just explained that to
me
because and people want to get into this
long conversation about oh
do you believe then you know there's
more than a a female and
i don't care what difference does it
make in my life
yeah it doesn't make a difference in my
[ __ ] life like i could tell you right
now
but you're supposed to make a difference
in their lives david
don't you see it's like okay so what on
this weight on your shoulders yeah
they're trying to have like these deep
conversations about like
gender and biology like there's a gender
i'm like
how about this i don't [ __ ] care it
just makes them feel smarter than you
yeah i was like i don't care they're
like well you should call me a he her
or he him i'm like cool what's up bro
what are you you what's you i was like
tell me whatever let's just move past
this part dude like i don't [ __ ] care
if this is something that's happening
like this is the trend that's going to
happen in the next 10 years
i ain't gonna fight it i don't [ __ ]
care yeah you want to come up and ask me
what my pronouns are and i say he
call me he if he's like hey listen bro
i'm
a monk seal so like somebody actually
called me an
old friend of mine like hey how's it
going i heard
your podcast on david's i just want to
say
all this [ __ ] up on me right it was like
and you
just you know still exude all this toxic
masculinity on the podcast
i'm like you have weird you know weird
people yeah i'm like yeah dude
why am i here so we can talk like toxic
masculine freely but that's it so
we can express our minds and our
confusions we still don't know what
we're talking like
it's a conversation yeah it's a
conversation we don't know what we don't
know yeah at least we're at that point
yeah but you know people say that to you
because they feel like if they say that
to you you're gonna crumble
you know that's why you know but the
thing about that too peop people don't
people like well i did what i did
you know and i'm i'm i did what was
righteous and i told this full off
actually you're an [ __ ] and all you
had to do was have a conversation
it didn't make you cool to go ahead and
go on this long diatribe [ __ ] on
somebody
because you felt that you were in the
position to teach somebody something and
chastise them
so now there is no conversation you let
you left a bad taste in my mouth dude
and it was since you put yourself there
out there on david's podcast
i'm going to put myself out there in my
dms
make your own podcast and say this you
say that [ __ ] like
when you want to talk to me as like on
one on one then you can have a
conversation
like here's a great example right uh i
was on the fighter and the kid with
brendan shop
right uh congratulations on that yeah so
they they hit me up and they're like hey
you want to come on the podcast i'm like
hey let's do it
like i love brendan shop's podcast yeah
right
and uh people were a little shocked
because when he brought up the whole
asian american thing and
you know i just i had a conversation
with him i was like oh he goes well
he was like is it really a hate hate
crime and i was trying to describe him
from my point of view
of how it can also be a hate crime and
also a sexual fetish because the sexual
fetishism has to do
with how people view asian women and
that's how he viewed asian women where
he felt that because
their bodies were owed to him he got
frustrated so there's a little bit of
both it can be both
right yeah i didn't yell at brenda's
shop i didn't go hey man how [ __ ]
dare you not know about this [ __ ]
why would i do that he asked a question
no no i'm
kudos to you too because i was actually
listening to it
at home with my roommate and my roommate
was like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
right
and then when you just laid it out it
was beautiful man
you you [ __ ] let him like he
he and he was receptive to it and you're
just like it's both
yeah whether he believes it or not we
had a very decent conversation
and that's the point people don't want
to do that now
why why should i be mad at brendan shaw
because he wants to have a conversation
about something that maybe he doesn't
know about and maybe there's something
that he's going to say that i don't know
about
because he gave me perspective about
people who don't understand yeah
right and he's not asian he's not going
to see it that way let it be known that
he doesn't understand
yeah right that's all that it is like
he's a dope ass [ __ ] dude yeah you
can't
get mad at somebody for not
understanding yeah
yeah that's my personal problem too
that's a lot of work i do
in my therapy with interactions with
people
and just being in society not everyone
understands and it's okay
it's not a [ __ ] personal attack on
you yeah
and that's what happens too right we we
get really personal with um
with with our hurt and we kind of
project it out to other people right
and so when he asked that question i
wasn't upset there was no reason to be
upset i'm like oh this is a
cool conversation to have with somebody
who isn't asian-american and may not
understand my perspective
and let's say we walked away from that
conversation he still doesn't get it
that's cool too
like as long as i said my piece on his
airwaves dude
yeah and it's perfectly fine you know
and i think too it's like
i think uh a lot of buddies hit me up
and they're like bro i can't believe you
asked him that i was like what did i ask
him he was like you asked him about a
stand-up special
right what i was like why not like i'm
saying that and i was like listen
you have to understand something there
is absolutely no way
that i would have been able to ask or
even have saw his stand-up special
if i wasn't a fan right i'm asking from
a fan's perspective
yeah you know what i mean that you had
to go and get a showtime subscription to
watch this to watch
do you think i'm some kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that went out of my way
to watch his standard special to watch
him fail yeah no i went to go see
something that because i see what my
boy's up to yeah like he was [ __ ]
funny on the rogan podcast
i like him on the king and the sting so
i saw a stand-up and i didn't like it
and i was like oh [ __ ] like as somebody
who's a fan of his i didn't enjoy it
and then he let me know his perspective
he was talking about well listen
if i didn't do that show times but
whether it was early or not or people
didn't think it was that great right
he goes i now have three more standard
specials with showtime
right that was the most viewed stand-up
special on showtime in the history
and and i remember clearly he he put it
to you where he was like
if you just started for six months and
then they offered you
of an hour special you're not gonna take
it
yeah i was like you don't know me at all
i'm a [ __ ]
you know and so that's the thing you
can't you can't [ __ ] lie to this guy
yeah right he's not a liar either right
yeah he's not a liar he's
faced some [ __ ] [ __ ] inside of an
octagon once he gotta [ __ ] lose after
yet right you british job is [ __ ]
cool dude like i
imagine being on that podcast and
hearing speak like he's a funny ass dude
like
there's no way i know this much stuff
about him if i'm not a fan
if not that i'm just a [ __ ] crazy
person he stepped up rogan's slaying
game too
he started using merc yeah that's
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast i
hope you made it up
i hope you enjoyed that episode you
could find ed at ed parkvp
you could also find his podcast at uh uh
bible study at momo yeah so go ahead and
check that out you'll see
genius brains every thursday and sundays
uh the last
week i was gone because that was
actually my first break from the podcast
in two
years nice so it it actually i needed
that you deserved it yeah
i [ __ ] needed it i didn't realize how
bad i needed it so
well we're back and we'll see you guys
every thursday and sundays and we'll see
you all next time
peace peace